now chile's military says the
coronavirus has reached
a research station in antarctica at
least 36 people have been infected at
their bernado o'higgins base
following an outbreak earlier this month
the announcement means the pandemic has
now reached every continent
on earth antarctic bases have been under
strict quarantine
antarctica one of the last truly
pristine places on earth
several nations maintain research
centers here chili's bernardo o'higgins
base is permanently staffed
and run by its military until now
researchers on the continent
thought they'd largely escaped the
coronavirus pandemic
then chile's military announced the
first cases
a pcr test showed that 36 men tested
positive for covert 19.
of which 26 were army personnel and 10
were civilians from a contracting
company
doing scheduled maintenance work
army officials confirmed another 21
people aboard a navy supply ship had
been infected
and one more case was detected at a
nearby research village
where the navy ship had docked
surrounded by icebergs and oceans the
research stations here are some of the
most remote on the planet
[Applause]
the arrival of the virus is concerning
doctors
they fear it could be much more
dangerous in such harsh conditions
we know that exposure to extreme weather
affects a person's physiology
isolation the change in seasonal light
with its seasonal sensitivity
can also be immunosuppressive we know
there are several components that may
further affect people
and lower their immune systems in
extreme conditions
especially with the work they do there
but so far none of the infected are said
to be experiencing
serious complications and with no other
countries having reported any cases
there is hope that the outbreak could be
containable
let's check in now on some other
developments in the pandemic
reports say that the drug maker pfizer
is close to a deal with the u.s to
supply
tens of hundreds of millions more doses
of its vaccine
in exchange the government will issue a
directive giving it better access to
supplies
south korea has recorded more than one
thousand new daily cases
that is putting the government under
pressure over its plans to wait till
february to start vaccinations
and the united arab emirates highest
islamic authority
has ruled that coronavirus vaccines are
acceptable
even though they contain pork gelatin
this comes after fears that muslims
would avoid the shot
because pigs are considered unclean in
islam